some of you may have noticed that I
recently did a nine-day total online
shutdown yeah that's right
for nine all-too-brief days I did not
look at my phone I did not check email I
did not look at Twitter and I did not
open Facebook I also did not open
snapchat but that was mainly because I
couldn't figure it out instead I took
the time and escaped for a belated
honeymoon and an overdue vacation in
Cabo Mexico most of my time there was
spent laying on the beach staring out
into the ocean and drinking copious
amounts of mojitos I got a little mojito
hint for you by the way just get it
without sugar you don't lose much in
taste ID you'll save a lot in health
anyway besides learning this lesson
about mojitos I also had a vital
revelation taking a break from the
online madness is not only incredibly
important I now view it as absolutely
necessary
think about how much time we all spend
staring into this little device we check
work emails when we're with loved ones
we Instagram pictures of food so it
looks tastier than it is and we live
tweet the minutiae of our lives to be a
hundred percent clear I am guilty of all
of these things to varying degrees and
I've been working hard to control this
ever growing online Beast it's not just
the silly often egocentric things that
we're doing online though it's also the
real-world events that were missing out
on while we stare into that little black
mirror when I wasn't staring into the
ocean or the skyline or when I was on
the beach I did plenty of people
watching I saw people from all ages
probably from about eight years old into
their 70s just staring down at their
phones almost all day long people were
ignoring their friends and family around
them and totally missing out on the
amazing ocean view that they paid to
have right in front of them
one afternoon I actually spent about two
hours watching a little kid play
dangerously close to the waves while his
parents were just sucked into the matrix
the whole time actually much of the
experience did remind me of the movie
The Matrix where we the humans are
really just batteries for this digital
world we might not be quite there yet
but we're certainly on our way
or actually maybe we are there and we
don't even know it yet I guess I'm just
waiting for Morpheus to offer me the red
pill though unfortunately I think most
people are gonna go blue pill all the
way after a couple days being offline I
felt more present less anxious and truly
freer than I felt in a long time when I
got back and I turned my phone on I had
this feeling of dread like here we go
again more than anything else
fortunately I quickly realized after
scanning my emails checking my Twitter
mentions and scrolling through Facebook
but not much had actually changed
without me I missed a couple of debates
our Stephen Fry interview went viral for
all the wrong reasons and I got a lot of
nice notes from you guys but beyond that
the world just kept spinning even if I
wasn't locked into it of course we all
know the world doesn't stop without us
but it felt good to know that it keeps
humming along with the good in the bad
whether or not we're paying attention
the whole time
of course I admit I'd make my living
here so this is a bit of a catch-22 I am
here in the online world not only that
but I do love most of it having honest
conversations about important issues
connecting with you guys and reshaping
my beliefs along the way have become my
life's ethos none of that would be
possible without this little gadget
despite that like everything else in
life there's a good and a bad a yin and
a yang a little more balance in life
probably never hurt any of us
my guest this week is steven crowder
like me steven is creating his success
with an online show with many modes of
distribution and by using social media
to amplify his voice interestingly while
I've spent so much of my time trying to
fix what I see wrong with my side the
left steven has spent much of his time
trying to fix what he sees wrong with
his side the right I realize more and
more every day the traditional labels of
left and right are losing all meaning
and the important piece of the puzzle is
finding people who will have a
good-faith battle of ideas and let the
chips fall where they may now close all
the other apps you have open ignore the
other person in the room with you and
let's have a discussion about politics
or go outside for a breath of fresh air
and look up in the stars though if you
do that please click play on our next
video
about the clicks these days you know all
about the clicks